la loi remonte et pour les kayakistes
quand le fleuve prend ses aises c'est le
terrain de jeu qui s'agrandit
[Musique]
ça change c'est pas mal on va aller à
d'autres endroits
ça permet de
ouais de se déplacer là aussi bien on va
entre les arbres et tout ça avec il ya
l'eau qui passe entre l'étape ça change
ça change beaucoup c'est un nouveau lieu
de pratique ça c'est assez amusant
pendant que certains s'amusent sur terre
la loire gonflée à bloc à son petit
succès de curiosité
ça faisait un moment qu'on l'avait pas
vu comme ça c'était assez basse je crois
avant les vacances de noël et là c'est
monter ses montées c'est impressionnant
c'est vrai que l'aller à ses hôtes et
disons assez dangereuse mais bon ça fait
partie du charme d'un d'un fleuve
sauvage en prévision de la crue
hivernale les lieux publics en bord de
loire sont sécurisés avec des
interdictions d'accès tandis que les
mariniers s'affaire à mettre leur bateau
à l'abri
nous en tant que marine et on est obligé
de mettre nos bateaux en sécurité vu que
ça charrie énormément darb donc pour la
mise en sécurité on les met en sécurité
à l'entrée du port donc dans le moule du
port pour pouvoir protéger nos bateaux
vue vous voyez ça charrie d'énormes
troncs d'arbres qu'on retrouve
actuellement sur nos comptant pour les
amoureux de la loire grandeur nature la
crue permet de naviguer au long cours
avec un bon moteur
la vraie loire c'est maintenant c'est ça
la loire c'est une hauteur d'eau faut
pas oublier que la marine de loire ou
xviiie siècle les dix mille bateaux qui
arrivent au pic de l'apogée de la marine
de loire il arrive quand il ya gros dos
c'est l'hiver qu'on navigue
toujours indomptables la loire inquiète
autant qu'elle fascine